whoever you are wherever you go someone
in this city wants to murder you
so they just admitted that the city is
not safe so why aren't they're walking
with an escort they can just be killed
at any moment this is the scene where
Sansa sends a letter to the Vale for
support and for whatever reason she
doesn't tell John what should I do
differently I don't know I don't know
anything about battles just just don't
do what he wants you to do nice good
advice
it was clearly discussed that Johnson
would not do anything stupid like Miss
placing himself but here we are and this
should be where jon snow dies because of
his dumb decision to got into the
battlefield but he gets saved by his
plot armor the dead are the enemy the
dead is that another figure of speech
the army of the dead is on the march you
army of the dead what the hell is John's
plan in this scene your strategy has
ocess dawn the Iron Islands and the
reach classic Tyrion failing at his job
as usual
does Shamy not understand that a dragon
is not incapacitated by a once spear in
his shoulder so bring the get to her
yeah this is just a stupid plan a much
better one would be to rescue Uncle
Benjen since he's proof of the White
Walkers and it would give his character
some relevance he can't pass through the
wall but you can just fly him over it
with a dragon get a raven to Daenerys
tell her what's happened you're the
fastest go no it doesn't make any sense
as to why Jon Snow expects Kendra to be
an Olympic marathon runner although it
turns out that he is one which is even
more stupid so this is what Tyrion has
to say about saving Danny's allies so
what would you have me do nothing
sometimes nothing is the hardest thing
to do Jon Snow is literally helping the
knight King here and the fact that he's
stalling and then after losing a dragon
Jon Snow doesn't even have the courtesy
to lie to Cersei about being loyal to
her
so his dumb actions just made everything
pointless the dead will come move first
enjoy dealing with them the whole feud
between Sansa and Arya is just dumb and
pointless it lasts all of season 7
because brain doesn't feel like telling
them that Littlefinger is a traitor
so Brandon the scenario is just being
stupid because he's causing all this
unnecessary conflict so let me detail
turians plan to change search his mind
first he complains about Tywin in spite
of what he did to me oh then he says he
destroyed Circe's family you love your
family and I have destroyed it I will
always be a threat so put an end to me
literally says that he wanted to kill
her
I've thought about killing you more
times than I can count
actively tries to commit suicide say the
word drinks a gallon of wine
and then finally at the end when things
get interesting since you figured out
that she's pregnant it cuts away those
who matter you're pregnant this is just
infuriating at this point David and Dan
can't write an intellectual scene for
the life of them this is like them
putting in fart jokes but wait they
already did so we had messed up the the
most kind of obvious storytelling
possibilities and HBO for some reason
decided to give us another channel you
must really be good in a meeting because
the idea that we here are the classic
first few lines of season 8 to show the
washed IQs of the two smartest
characters in the show least your balls
won't freeze off you take great
defensive tortures but love telling you
new turns why is that because I have
bowls you don't we have never had a
conversation last this long without you
insulting me not once
I guess Brienne has developed amnesia as
a side effect from the horrendous
writing because she literally has his
five minute conversation with Jamie in
the scene the fact that Samwell thinks
he's suddenly a warrior just hurts need
me how bad well if that's what it's come
to we really are focused well calling
you [ __ ] wouldn't be strictly accurate
I'm not abandoning most people take this
and go
I don't know how to use it one of the
smartest characters in season 8 doesn't
know how to use a knife okay what kind
of person climbs on the [ __ ] dragon
I'm mad man that's some great continuity
there torment you are my queen I don't
know what else I can say this is just a
big nut punch - Jon Snow's intelligence
Dany is literally distressed and you're
my queen is the only thing this guy can
muster then I [ __ ] you not he stands up
and says the exact same thing you are my
queen it's honestly just hard to believe
at this point the new Prince of Dorne
that is his support no matter how many
Lords turn against her as long as she
sits on the Iron Throne she can call
herself Queen at the Seven Kingdoms so
various just told Danny about Doran
support and she just brushes it off and
basically says it doesn't matter how
many Lords support her
like what then the classic having a
flying playdate over a potentially
hostile territory with her dragons scene
happens we all know where this one's
going have you considered the best route
it might be someone who doesn't want to
rule we're discussing treason discussing
treason in a public hall that echos her
voice like a true master of whisperers
she also just tells John that he's
committing treason but it's not like
John has the brain functionality to
understand what's happening anyways I
don't want to see the city burn I don't
want to hear the screams of children
burn him alive
no it is not a pleasant sound so in this
clip Tyrion is failing at a simple level
of persuasion saying I don't like this
and that will not persuade someone who
was opposed to you this is also a very
integral moment antarians career because
he's trying to prevent a war but he's
too dumb to do so how did they find you
did you consider taking it off in season
seven
Jamie remember to cover his hand so why
does he miraculously lose half of his
brain cells and not cover a golden hand
in public where they keep the dragon
skulls beneath the red keep
take her down there keep following the
stairways down down as far as they'll go
you'll come out on to a beach at the
foot of the keep Tyrion wants to do
everything to avoid the upcoming
conflict of King's Landing so why
doesn't he
relay this information to Daenerys I'm
gonna kill know what I see what there's
nothing in the world more powerful than
a good story I think Tywin would have
something to say about that
nothing can stop it and who has a better
story than brand the broken yeah okay
literally the only reason why Tyrion pig
ran was because he was the only person
he actually talked to I don't think
Tyrion knows about anyone else's story
so he just picked brand out of process
of elimination a very genius way in
determining the next king of Westeros
indeed